[Music]
while the movie Cannonball Run was
slapstick it was based on real-life
efforts to race from coast to coast and
last month a seemingly unbeatable record
was broken three car enthusiasts made it
from a garage here in New York City to a
hotel in Redondo Beach California at a
heart-pounding speed with a top speed of
193 miles per hour and an average of 103
for more than a day
drivers are Neto Minh and Doug Cabot
along with spotter Berkley Chadwick are
the new Cannonball Run record holders as
first reported by Road and track the
team made the 2800 miles from New York
to Los Angeles in 27 hours 25 minutes
shaving more than an hour off the old
mark set in 2013 while in the movie Burt
Reynolds and Dom DeLuise crossed the
country in an ambulance the team rode in
a souped up Mercedes modified over the
course of two years specifically with
setting the record in mind we've got a
couple radar detectors a CB radio a
police scanner
we use gyro-stabilized binoculars and
something new for this trip that's never
been done as we used a thermal scope on
the roof of the car so we're able to see
anything warm on the side of the road
waiting up before us
they were also aided by a network of
spotters driving ahead of them and
reporting road conditions along with the
placement of police speed traps we knew
we had a shot pretty much the whole time
and thankfully nothing bad happened
there was no altercations with the
police or anything to slow us down
but the feat is drawing criticism from
safety experts the governor's Highway
Safety Association says
speeding is widely deemed culturally
acceptable by the motoring public we
need to change that narrative and make
speeding as socially unacceptable as
drunk driving
Tomin maintains the team never put any
other drivers at risk
there was no close calls at all we don't
pass people at a high rate of speed
simply because it's dangerous and if we
were to do that to drive recklessly
they're just going to call the police
and then we're just going to have police
waiting for us
seen in that picture there the GPS
screen they stopped for a total of 22
minutes and obviously do not try this do
not try this that is a very serious
concern yes